regulators in the financial markets of
america have been arguing over whether
bitcoin ethereum and other crypto assets
are securities or not this debate has
raged on for years and it has left many
market participants completely in the
dark how should they move forward how
should they treat these assets what's
inbounds and what is out of bounds will
we finally have some regulatory clarity
earlier today in an industry conference
sec chairman gary ginzer came forward
and said that he would back a plan by
legislators to have bitcoin and ethereum
regulated by the cftc not the sec this
means that bitcoin and ethereum would be
recognized as commodities not securities
and therefore the cftc would have
jurisdiction but what this does is it
opens up the opportunity for the sec to
characterize every other asset more than
20 000 of them as securities and give
them oversight over that long tail of
crypto assets if those other assets are
considered securities the sec believes
that companies like coinbase gemini
kraken and many others would have to
register with the sec because they would
be trading securities on their platform
obviously the market participants they
do not believe those other assets are
securities they do not believe that they
are actually allowing securities to
trade on their platform and so that is
where the debate is going to move to
next
but the big news today is that bitcoin
and ethereum are both now looking to be
not securities by the sec to have the
sec chairman come out and say you know i
would be okay with the cftc overseeing
the two largest crypto assets that's a
pretty big deal it remains to be seen
whether this will actually occur how
legislation will move forward whether
the cftc will get the amount of money
they're looking for to beef up their
oversight of the bitcoin and eat their
market but it is a very big development
that the sec chairman now says that he
would be okay with this playing out and
what it does do is it shifts the focus
to all those other assets will there be
securities or will they not depending on
who you ask in the legacy financial
market in the regulatory world or if you
ask somebody in the crypto world
everyone has a different opinion but at
the end of the day getting regulatory
clarity remains one of the biggest
hurdles for the industry getting
regulatory clarity does not mean that
regulators will end up implementing the
rules that you want
simply means that there will be clarity
clarity is good because it allows for
entrepreneurs investors innovators and
market participants to know what's
allowed and what's not allowed it
provides an incentive system it also
provides a punishment framework so that
people aren't operating thinking about
every single day what randomly may end
up being their fate naturally regulatory
clarity something that everyone wants
but my big guess is when it comes there
will be a lot of people who are unhappy
bitcoin and ether appear to not be a
security that's good news for everyone
in the market who wanted that outcome
but there are a lot of other assets that
still we do not have answers hopefully
those answers will come in the short
term keep paying attention to this area
it's still one of the biggest obstacles
for large amounts of capital come into
the industry and there's still a lot of
financial institutions who want to play
in the space but they're nervous until
more regulatory clarity comes hey you
did you like this video great make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time